daring different distinctive after its
c4 cactus now cinta one is also given
the c3 a flashy er design but will
potential customers like it the c3 is an
especially important model for its maker
accounting for one in five sets one sold
in Europe the air bumps guarding the
side doors are already familiar from the
cactus mats and our car toaster enos p3
says the C 3 s curves and smooth
surfaces make it look the way around
peppermint drop feels on your tongue the
exterior design avoids edges and corners
but while easy on the eye it's far from
boring the accents on the fog lamps and
exterior mirrors match the color of the
roof the front takes its cue from Ronnie
SUV crossover models and boasts three
lamp units on each side the air bumps on
the doors are optional but they make a
big contribution to the C 3s conspicuous
look
9 exterior colors and 3 more for the
roof provide a selection of 36 different
color combinations the c3 loses some
points with its trunk
whether loading or unloading you have to
heem your cargo over this tall trunk
sill and when you put the back seats
down the resulting surface has a big
bump not pretty and not practical we
test-drove the c3 with the most powerful
of the 3 gasoline engines available the
1.2 liter 3-cylinder engine produces 81
kilowatts and a substantial 205 Newton
meters of torque and that's at just 1500
RPM our test car comes with a top
equipment package shine and the price
just under 18,000 euros in Germany
[Music]
but then I don't know Tina says 81
kilowatts will take you down a country
road at a fast pace but the fun of
driving is dulled a bit by the loose
steering you have to turn the wheel
quite a bit before the car responds and
the manual 5-speed transmission responds
a bit slowly to Vega behind the sin line
a six-speed Automatic transmission
promises faster shifting although it's
available only in combination with the
most powerful engine
the designers left nothing to chance in
the interior Ennis notes everywhere
inside components take up the motif of
the side door air bumps the c3 s
interior is similarly unconventional
while the competition is working hard to
make everything flow smoothly around the
driver here everything is very angular
with lots of color variety and attention
to detail
I didn't wear the see threes exterior is
all curves and smooth surfaces as eNOS
the interior straight lines and 90
degree angles reminder of a cubicle
Swiss herb candy that gives driver and
passengers plenty of room to move
greenness the interior seems as if the
engineers constructed it around an
imaginary box among optional extras are
practical assists including a parking
aid a blind spot alert system and
traction control to reduce wheel
spinning
eNOS says you can connect your cell
phone with the car through the central
console operating unit the radio can be
controlled the old-fashioned way with a
knob to change the volume but many other
buttons have been eliminated the air
conditioning and heater can only be
operated via the touchscreen and since
the display is located rather low down
it definitely diverts your eyes from the
road monitors and diction finestra's in
on battling the car itself however has
its gaze firmly fixed ahead and it can
save images in case of an accident
I know technical special in the Citroen
c3 is this dash cam says eNOS since when
calls it the connected cam and it's
integrated behind the mirror you can
take pictures or shoot short film clips
of the road ahead as you drive and then
share them with friends on the social
networks
[Music]
hey gal enas sums up part round
peppermint dropped part herb candy cube
sit - on c3 is an interesting mixture
that will get attention on the road the
c3 has also won the attention of a jury
of design experts this July the car will
be awarded the renowned red dot award
[Applause]